another scientifically inaccurate and
potentially harmful statement made by
another celebrity about health it's no
surprise but we're talking about it on
this week's Wednesday checkup I found
out last week that Lady gaga
sat down to have an open and honest
conversation with Oprah about her mental
health this conversation talked about
her own journey breaking the mental
health stigma that exists and addressing
disparities now all those things are
incredibly important and I'm actually
really passionate about addressing those
issues in fact many of my patients who
are uninsured or only have catastrophic
insurance they face a really tough task
in finding a mental health counselor
therapist psychiatrist and it's my job
as a family medicine doctor it's not
only fill that void but also help them
navigate this really tricky system that
we have here in the United States when
it comes to mental health stigma this
absolutely needs to be broken but in
order to break the mental health stigma
we need honest and accurate information
when we talk about someone having a
mental health issue that's not to say
that they're weak it's not to say that
there's something wrong with them but
diagnosing ourselves is not the solution
reading a book and saying oh I must have
X Y & Z and now I need to self treat
myself also is not ideal the most ideal
way to go about getting proper mental
health treatment is a to see a licensed
therapist psychiatrist or primary care
physician and I say primary care
physician because there is a specific
segment within Lady Gaga's speech that
is harmfully inaccurate by the way if
your primary care doctor is prescribing
you an antidepressant this should not be
happening primary care doctors should be
introducing you to a psychiatrist and
expert in brain medication now as a
primary care doctor a board-certified
family medicine physician my problem
with this statement is not personal
offense lady gaga
did not offend me by saying this
statement but what she is saying is
scientifically inaccurate and it's wrong
factually let's start off on a practical
note let's talk about the numbers the
National Institutes of Health estimates
that one in five adults will have a
mental health issue
when I say issue a classifiable mental
health disorder that equates to about 40
to 66 million individuals with a
condition now there's only about 20
something thousand practicing
psychiatrists in the u.s. how are all
those people going to get care and on
top of that there's certain geographic
limitations where there are no
practicing psychiatrists in a given area
then there's people who have lower
socioeconomic standing who are uninsured
and have higher rates of mental illness
what are they supposed to do Lady gaga
second we don't want to put even more
stress on our overburdened mental
healthcare system
think about this psychiatrists are
specialists in what they do and they
should be seeing more complex cases if
every single time any patient that
needed antidepressant needed to be
referred to them think about the
incredible way times that that would
create for patients who are truly
complex and can't be treated by family
medicine doctors this will completely
break already nearly broken system in
fact psychiatrists and other specialists
that I've worked with in the past have
sometimes laid the complaint at my feet
that some family medicine providers are
too quick to refer instead of trying
first-line treatments like
antidepressants and I completely agree
with that which goes completely against
what Lady Gaga was trying to say in this
speech three board certified family
medicine doctors receive extensive
education and training in mental health
conditions and brain medications with
the ability to refer or triage as needed
in reality it's the actual job of the
family medicine doctor to be able to
administer first line and even second
line treatments before sending the
patient to a specialist if you try the
first line treatment it fails maybe you
try the second line treatment it fails
then you need a specialist if you need
to perform a procedure that you're not
trained in or you don't have the
equipment to perform you need to send to
a specialist if you've come across a
complex case with a patient having more
than one illness or taking more than one
medication that could be high enough
complexity to warrant a referral perhaps
you're not comfortable with the specific
illness that the patient has and you
don't have enough experience with it
that warrants our referral but these are
the minority of cases the huge majority
of patients
anxiety and depression who warned
antidepressants can and should be
treated by primary care doctors also as
a side note not every patient with
anxiety and oppression needs
antidepressants and in fact that's the
beauty of family medicine we understand
that cognitive behavioral therapy DBT
all these options work very well for our
patients and because we have existing
relationships with these patients
because we're their primary care
providers we treat them for years we
know what works we know what medications
they do well with they have direct
access to us and it only makes sense
that we continue this line of treatment
until it passes that complexity line
where we do need to get a specialist
like a psychiatrist involved for I think
there's a faulty mentality at the heart
of this statement where more money spent
always yields better care or outcomes
and that's just not the case in reality
I have many celebrity or wealthy
patients that come in to see me that
request every single test or every
single treatment and I have to explain
to them that tests come with possible
risks treatments come with possible
risks even though some of them may seem
completely benign like a blood test and
we need to have those conversations now
you may be wondering to yourself how is
seeing a specialist putting me at risk
well it's not directly putting you at
risk because specialists are very
confident they know what they're doing
but from my experience what I've seen is
if a patient who does not have a primary
care doctor gets sent to a specialist
too early they sometimes get treatments
or even tests for things that they don't
need yet this is not because the
specialist don't know what they're doing
or because they're trying to push things
on to the patient it's because they're
used to seeing more complex cases so
they have a lower threshold of when to
order certain tests or certain
treatments and they don't have existing
relationships with these patients like
we do as primary care providers for
example I have some patients that when
they come in and they say their pain
levels of four or five I get really
worried because I already know they have
a very high pain threshold but if they
go see a cardiologist they say oh my
pain is a for maybe it's not taken as
seriously if you jump on to any review
site you'll see patients complaining
that they didn't get
or treatments from their doctor and they
think that's a bad thing but I recently
came across a tweet from a dr. Christina
Johns that I think works very well in
this case it reads just because no tests
were performed or medicines prescribed
it doesn't mean that you didn't get care
I completely agree with the statement
because it takes careful evaluation to
know what a patient has to weigh the
risks and benefits of each procedure and
each treatment and figure out what's
right for the individual sitting in
front of you that's why generalizations
don't work well in medicine and that's
why Lady gaga statement here does more
harm than good at the end of the day it
puts patients at risk who would
otherwise go get care from a family
medicine doctor it hurts existing
doctor-patient relationships that are
potentially going very well I guess the
final thing that really makes a
statement inaccurate is that pretty much
every medical organization agrees that
family medicine doctors are more than
capable and are trained to prescribe
antidepressants to know when to refer
patients if the complexity arises and to
make a universal statement like that
that disagrees with all of medicine just
doesn't make a lot of sense just four
days ago the active president of the AFP
dr. Leroy made a great statement family
medicine physicians are on the front
lines of mental health care in America
and I completely agree with that
statement do you know why I would
actually go as far as to say 80% of my
visits there is a mental health care
component so when a patient comes in for
back pain acid reflux diabetes chronic
care management those usually have a
mental health component in them whether
we see it or not whether we diagnose it
or not and if we're gonna go ahead and
make a universal statement and say
family medicine doctors shouldn't
prescribe antidepressants or they're
incapable to take care of mental health
it just flat-out wrong I'm dropping some
great resources down below including a
response from the American Academy of
Family Physicians and a fantastic open
letter by dr. Megan Babb on the subject
I encourage you to read it a lot of the
same points I brought up in this video
were addressed in her letter as well and
we really should send a message to Lady
gaga and really all influential
celebrities out there your message is
going to be heard by millions of people
they're gonna trust you because you're a
familiar
face they have respect for you so if
you're going to be making Universal
recommendations about health care please
PLEASE partner with a medical
organization partner with a medical
professional before more harm than good
is done with those statements if you're
interested to watch some of my other
videos about mental health which I'm
very passionate about as an osteopathic
and holistic physician click here as
always stay happy and healthy
[Music]